- OK. Come on!
Let's go get some peas.
- C'est l'heure de la cueillette
pour Michelle et ses deux
enfants. Le repas du
sera confectionné uniquement
avec des aliments du jardin.
Cette famille va à l'épicerie
à peine une fois par mois.
- C'est une question de qualité
de vie. J'adore vivre ici,
j'adore que mes ssss
habitent ici.
- Cette vie loin de la ville,
Michelle et son obobobob
en rêvent depuis 14 ans.
Alors qu'ils poursuivent
une carrière à Calgary comme
ingénieurs dans le secteur
pétrolier, ils voyagent
en Europe et en Amérique latine
pour apprendre à réduire
leur empreinte écologique.
"On a vite réalisé
qu'il fallait surtout apprendre
l'agriculture durable
pour assurer un bel avenir
à nos enfants", dit-elle.
Lee e e e découvre
la permaculture, un ensemble
de méthodes agricoles plus
respectueuses des écosystèmes.
Depuis deux ans, dans le centre
de l'Alberta, la famille opére
un véritable retour à la nature.
"Notre but, c'est de produire
le moins de déchets possibles,
d'être des producteurs
plutôt que des consommateurs
et de rendre ce sol riche
pour les décennies à venir",
explique-t-elle.
Les enfants, eux,
se sont vite adaptés.
"Je préfère vivre ici,
dit Naomi. On peut faire
des randonnées sans prendre
la voiture et il y a toujours
des choses à faire
dans le jardin."
Cette vie au vert n'empêche pas
Michelle de travailler.
Avec son mari, ils donnent
des cours sur Intern
pour partager leur savoir.
Leur chainubububube comptabilise
plus de six millions de vues.
Les visites sur leur site
ont doublé pendant la pandémie.
Pour l'instant,
ils ne produisent que
la moitié de leur nourriture
eturururur énergie.
Leur prochain projet
leur permettra de recupérer
l'eau de pluie. Il leur faudra
du temps et de l'argent pour
être réellement autosuffisants.
Ici Axel Tardieu,
Radio-Canada, Winfiel